wenn du den muezzinruf hörst den du aus
deiner heimat ursprünglich aus
bangladesch kennst was empfindest du
dabei
das erinnert mich
an meine blogger freunde sechs blogger
freunde die von islamisten getötet
wurden das engagement all das erinnert
mich tot um das erinnert mich hitze
gegen gegen minderheiten
vor allem die frauen in bangladesch und
ich musste 2005 sinnvoll islamisten aus
bangladesch nach deutschland geflohen
und ich bin hier wegen für meine
freiheit ist will ich nicht mehr so was
holen dass das ist nicht nur ein das ist
nicht nur ahnen wir dass ardian das ist
auch ein zeichen der diskriminierung das
ist auch ein zeichen
hitze gegen juden gegen city crew und
gegen frauen deswegen hast du das auch
getwittert zu dieser diskussion um den
muezzin ruft dort in köln noch einmal
die nachricht ist ja aus köln dass die
stadt das eben erlaubt dass man möchte
dass der muezzin ruf auch in zukunft in
köln ertönen kann um den muslimen dort
in der stadt gerecht zu werden dass die
idee auch der oberbürgermeisterin die
sagt mensch da ist doch nichts böses an
diesem ruf sonne das ist ein zeichen von
unserem respekt den muslimischen glauben
gegenüber das hätte ganz anderes das ist
nicht ein zeichen der vielfalt wie sie
schreibt aus meiner erfahrung ist ein
klares zeichen
der diskriminiert dass sie die falsche
voll das ist die falsche toleranz
philipp ihr tief bei uns im studio chef
unseres meinungs- ressorts ein ganz
falsches zeichen köln will sich so gerne
als weltoffene präsentieren die
oberbürgermeisterin die spricht von
einem zeichen des respekts und
vielerorts wird der ruf des muezzin
verglichen mit kirchengeläut in der
domstadt in köln warum ist das für dich
nicht das gleiche ich glaube wir haben
gerade von chamier sehr gut gehört warum
das nicht ganz so gut vergleichbar ist
wenn man ein zeichen der vielfalt setzen
möchte dann sollte man etwas
möglich machen etwas erlauben was
vielleicht auch selbst für vielfalt
steht und dieser martin ruf steht für
ganz viele menschen auf dieser welt nun
einmal nicht für vielfalt sondern er
steht für die durchsetzung der einen
religion oder eben gar nichts und das
ist verbunden mit der diskriminierung
von vielen menschen die schau mir auch
gerade aufgezählt hat die sie auch
selbst erfahren hat deswegen frage ich
mich wurden eigentlich auch andere
menschen befragt die sich davon
diskriminiert fühlen können köln ist
beispielsweise eine sehr tolerante stadt
wenn es gerade um die lgbt community
geht wie empfinden des denn diese
menschen oder was bedeutet der muezzin
ruf denn für diese menschen wir sprechen
hier nicht über die riesige mehrheit von
ganz friedlichen ganz normalen muslimen
sondern wir sprechen noch über moschee
verbände die sehr problematisch sind und
wie die zu homosexuellen zu juden zu
frauen stehen das ist leider sehr gut
bekannt beziehungsweise es ist zum glück
sehr gut bekannt aber man tut viel zu
wenig dagegen man kommt diesen verbänden
jetzt entgegen im namen einer vielfalt
die diese verbände selbst aber überhaupt
nicht bewerben nicht ausstrahlen also
nach kölle alaaf kölle alaaf in der
domstadt eben philipp das ist ein
modellprojekt das heißt da sind bisher
auch noch nicht allzu viel anträge
eingegangen einen antrag sagte im specks
aber die nachricht ist ja auch noch
relativ frisch dass man sich da
sozusagen um dem würzigen ruf bewerben
kann ab jetzt die verschiedenen
moscheegemeinden ein modellprojekt
glaubst du dass man davon noch mal
runter kommt weil die frage ist doch
wenn das einmal in unseren alltag
eingekehrt ist dann wird es ja
wahrscheinlich riesen diskussion
auslösen wenn man anschließend sagt okay
das hat man jetzt zwei jahre gemacht
jetzt aber wieder weg mit dem beruf also
so wie frau reger die kölner
oberbürgermeisters eingeführt hat hört
sich das für mich schon relativ
endgültig an wenn man davon spricht dass
man ein zeichen des respekts ein zeichen
der vielfalt aussendet und deshalb den
ruf möglich gemacht wird man ja wohl
nicht in einem monat sagen jetzt senden
ziehen wir unser zeichen des respekts
zurück jetzt sind wir eine weniger
respektvolle weniger tolerante weniger
vielfältige stadt so wie ich frau rieke
verstehe steht sie voll dahinter
möchte das durchsetzen und ich glaube
vielen kölnern wird das etwas übel
aufstoßen auch weil der vergleich zur
kirchenglocke einmal vorne und hinten
nicht taugt das eine ist eine ganz
normale mechanische glocke das andere
ist ein mann der in ein mikrofon brüllt
allahu akbar gott ist groß und es gibt
keinen gott außer allah das ist etwas
anderes das ist ein sehr dominantes
zeichen das ist etwas was zumindest in
diesen minuten in denen das freitags
ertönt
aus köln durchaus etwas anderes macht
vom gefühl her ich glaube das wird
vielen menschen zu denken geben wie
fühlt sich das für dich ein chemie stell
dir vor wenn das modellprojekt sich
durchsetzen und auch in anderen städten
kommt du bist genau was sie gerade
geschildert
dieser tendenz griff logo wolltest
diesen ruf auch nicht mehr hören du bist
geflohen als von freundinnen berichtet
die von islamisten getötet worden was
löst das bei dir aus es gibt viele
frauen männern wie ich sie von
islamisten geflohen sind und sie sind
sie haben einen schubs in deutschland
gefunden ich finde wirklich schade
dass wir sind und wir mussten unser
heimatländer verlassen nun wir wollten
freiheit wir wollten nicht mehr solche
slogan holen und jetzt müssen viele
kunden ich kenne viele ex muslime
community aber sie sind in köln ich habe
mit denen ist es pflicht werfen sie
spricht man von uns und meine meinung
lang köln ist vielfältig ohne sim lock
und köln soll vielfältig so bleiben
[Musik]